nous vous convions maintenant à nous
suivre dans une station de sports
d'hiver pas comme les autres cette
station c'est avoriaz la station de jean
vuarnet jean vuarnet été l'un des
promoteurs de cette station qui sur le
côté architectural a été bâti par
l'atelier d'architecturé d'avoriaz
composé de jacques labro jean-jacques
orsoni et jean marc roques
mais passons en revue les diverses
raisons qui font que cette station n'est
pas du tout comme les autres
je regardais jean vuarnet vous venez de
faire le tour de la station d'avoriaz zh
avec un moyen de transport peu comme
pourquoi et bien si vous voulez c'est
l'illustration finale devant nous nos
trois grands principes qui régissent
l'importation d'avoriaz à savoir la
station sans voiture et pour bien
frapper l'imagination dont on fait venir
des rennes de laponie finlande avec des
traîneaux très typique que vous avez vus
à l'instinct vous savez que les deux
autres principes sont d'une part
l'adaptation absolue et totale du
fonctionnement de notre station au ski
c'est à dire que l'implantation des
chances qui dépistent ont présidé à
l'implantation du plan masse par les
architectes et enfin troisième point le
dépaysement dépaysement que nous
recherchons non pas en chercher à faire
des chalets souvenirs ou de chair les
types suisse mais une architecture
moderne parfaitement adaptés adapté au
site est néanmoins je voulais qu'ils ont
ensemble en aucune façon à ce qu'on
appelle communément les valises dire ces
espèces de d'immeubles classique qu'on
trouve parfaitement dans les villes et
qui ne dépayse pas les touristes de nos
stations
si vous deviez donner un slogan cours à
votre station lequel serait-il je crois
que ce serait quand même avec nos reines
avoriaz station sans voiture je crois
que dans votre station vous avez voulu
différencier et les deux types de
circulation
expliquez-nous ce plan vous voyez
clairement que les skieurs passent au
dessus de circulation celle que l'on
voit lié à gauche circulation lourde qui
servent aux services publics et les
circulations légère qui sont des
promenades ou des navettes intérieur à
la station au nord vous voyez d un
bonhomme qui arrive avec ses skis et au
sud nous envoyer un autre qui part avec
ses skis autrement dit ce schéma
illustre bien la façon dont les gens
vivront dans la station c'est à dire
qu'ils se déplaceront uniquement et ce
qui est bien après avoir vu les
maquettes de tous nos projets nouveaux
si maintenant sur le terrain et vous
pouvez voir les premières réalisations
ces réalisations sont d'un caractère
extrêmement moderne très original aussi
je crois
conçu par une bande de jeunes
architectes qui ont désiré chercher
aussi bien à s'adapter au site par le
caractère de l' architecture de même
qu'il l'avait fait pour le plan masse
les bâtiments vous pouvez voir ici
bien que n'étant pas encore complètement
terminé seront complètement transformé
lorsqu'ils se rendent couvert
entièrement en bois il s'agit de
de toit en bois cèdre rouge comme nous
appelons ici ces éléments l'état rayons
les enseignes comme vous voudrez et bien
voici maintenant nous sommes veut pas
être là vu que vont tous les habitants
des immeubles qui donnent tous sur les
pistes en plein sud
dès maintenant les touristes de morzine
peuvent venir ce qu'est avons rien avec
de nombreuses pistes et des
installations à ces extraordinaires
notamment notre notre énorme
téléphérique qui débite plus de 1000
personnes à l'heure et qui est le plus
rapide du monde avec ses 2 mètres 25
secondes
nous avons également un télésiège qui
fonctionne un grand et les skis un plus
petit pour les débutants et nous sommes
un peu pris de court
nous sommes en train de terminer un
télésiège et un téléski qui présenteront
sur plateau devant rien les champs de
ski pour tous débutants
je pense que dès l'année prochaine nous
serons avec quelques centaines de lits
fort bien équipé
au point de vue remontées mécaniques
avec ce programme entièrement réalisés